bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show purpose of life that
is what the Deen show is all about
calling you to reflect to think to
ponder why you've been created while
you're here where you're going when you
die and that's what we're all about here
on the Deen show and our next guest the
NFL players the Abdullah brothers
sacrificing for the Deen leaving off
playing football cats touch and accept
all of that for the Deen taking off
training to go to Hajj the fifth pillar
of this beautiful way of life fastened
during the month of Ramadan playing the
sport and not giving up there Dean for
the dunya they're here with us on the D
show the Abdullah brothers we'll be
right back
[Music]
mrs. the teens the thing
[Music]
you know this is the things just Athene
jus
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to the Deshawn adeno
studio as promised we got our brothers
Hamza and Hussein peace be on to you
Salaam alaikum
walaikum asalam until I would have got
this not only can I come to life and if
football superstars not superstars just
regular guys so you kick the ball a lot
balls we can go we run and hit people
and tackle people okay so we're talking
about NFL we're talking about NFL and
not football with the a shake over the
top okay like in Europe yes yeah says
this is football okay so for all the
soccer fans you know what we're going to
tell my football today a little bit of
the Deen of cousins you're watching the
D show so you guys you know because you
guys have turned the world thank you for
stopping incident to Chicago over here
tell us a little but your your your a
trip you guys play for the NFL how long
you play for that NFL for I've actually
played for years all four years with the
Minnesota Vikings the first two
predominately the special teams player
the last two of the starting safety
starting say what's starting safety what
is that I'm a defender I'm the last line
of defense
typically if they get past me it's a
touchdown so it's a it's a very tough
job we can see here that you're like how
come they're throwing the ball to
another guy but you took the bar you
cheating well no that's mine that's my
job soon as the ball goes up in there
it's anybody's ball and I'm gonna come
down with it so that's called an
interception that's definite
interceptions okay I'm a safety as well
but unlike I'm saying I don't have any
interceptions I'm I tried to make myself
a big hitter and you know big collision
so I'm like a big truck on the highway I
just want to crash into people so you're
not knocking people down
inshallah so now you're on a road trip
and you guys are visiting different
mustard all over the US tell us all
about this project humbly law thirty
months is in 30 days insha'Allah we we
just were brainstorming and we say you
know what we want to meet some of the
brothers and the sisters that have sent
us a kind word sent us a tweet or a
Facebook post and we
just say assalamu alaikom and show them
that we are their brother and sister in
Islam you know we're not elevated to
some high status where their brother and
sister in Islam so we are embarking in
Shiloh on a road trip and insha'Allah
you know Allah will make it easy for us
you like yeah I'll just say a lot of
people think because of our profession
that we're up here but we're it we're on
the same playing field as everyone else
we just happen to play a game that
people love and watch so they give you a
status I'll just say but we're we're
normal people just like everybody else
and that's what this trip is about just
to go around and say you know we're
Muslim just like you we go through it
just like you but in that you can't
succeed at what you want to do in life
that's deep so you guys are you know
going out of your way to go and meet
your brothers and sisters out there in
the O Muhammad to see you giving them
some advice I'm like whatever we can do
our mother was a stickler on running for
your brother what you want for yourself
and I remember as a kid when I was 12
years old being in the Hakeem Olajuwon
basketball camp and what that did for me
so I imagined myself being in that
position you know I'm not nowhere near I
came alive on he's a superstar
hall-of-famer but you know just being in
the aspect and the light that we have we
want to share some good and we wanted to
come meet our brothers because we would
want how came Elijah want to come meet
him as he did that steep so you guys
make sure that you guys are gonna be
heading towards where's where's the
schedule of all the moistures that you
guys are gonna be you can you can find
it on Abdullah Bros comm we have a
schedule up and we've been hitting all
the different messages across the year
well not all of them as many as we can
hit within these 30 days we know that
Islam is is a way of life of love and
mercy is the way of peace having peace
with your Creator peace within yourself
and peace with the rest of mankind
listen so now you guys live in Islam
you're out there and the public eye do
you sometimes get some scrutiny do you
guys with all the you know boogeyman
Islam is coming to get you you know you
hear it on the news a lot of times but
people get to interact with you and you
know your teammates do you ever get in
any slack because be you guys are ones
who submitted to the will of God Muslims
well I would say the number one thing in
the number one exam
is how we carry ourselves and that's the
way of the Dean you know Hum Dil I
wanted the Dean show so we're talking
about our Dean the regardless of what
our neighbor sees on the news if he sees
you and says brother Eddie is a Muslim
he takes care of me he invites me over
to his house he takes care of my lawn if
his if he if I see that his garbage cans
are out an extra day he will bring them
in those are the acts that you know in
Islam a form of peace and we're always
trying to do good and always trying to
be as good as possible so that will come
back the ignorance of what is outside
whether it's on the news on the internet
or whatever it is us just walking our
path us on our deen inshallah we'll
overcome all of that have you met any
other athletes are like Muhammad Ali
we're not Hopkins who are there's a lot
of people who are Muslim and after you
saw that we met any of them there's a
lot of people who are Muslim and answers
but we have not met too many of them
we've met Ryan Harris Thomas actually
played with him for the Denver Broncos
Ryan Harris right here yes he plays for
the Denver Broncos but inshallah one of
our goals on this trip is to go and
knock down some doors initially we get a
chance to sit with some of our brothers
in this one there's a great opportunity
that all the people out the woodwork
maybe there's something that you know
now they're like how we can contact we
can make this happen in Charlotte and
Charlotte we're gonna take a break and
we right back with more with the
Abdullah brothers here on the Dean show
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here on earth
with this my job to go into someone's
heart to change the heartbeat your job
is to topi what the truth is and the
ally of it is while we're sitting here
while I'm sitting here constantly paying
for the disease to kill was free
[Music]
[Music]
back here on the Dean show we're talking
to our
the our brothers the Abdullah brothers
NFL you guys been playing for a long
time and you're out there people think
you like you were saying you're up here
so you're coming down here to meet your
brothers and sisters in the Dean and how
about how about if you got some fans who
are not yet Muslim that's right I want
to come out and they want to meet you
guys what about that is that okay that's
no problem we were reaching out to
everybody part of this trip is to meet
Muslims and non-muslims alike to let
people know that just because you wear a
shoulder pads and a helmet and there's
an NFL stitch on your Jersey it doesn't
mean you're better than anybody else
we're on the same playing field as I've
said before so if you're a non-muslim
please come out or our schedule is
online and you can come to any of them
aside you're you're more than welcome to
come out and meet us and that's what we
encourage you know because some people
think man the musters they did the
mosques we got a bomb-making factory
over there come on in bring the bring
your whole family come eat biryani with
us or hot dogs
oh yeah one of my favorite times of the
year is Ramadan because the mosques are
open there's so many people and that's a
great form of Dawa to bring your
neighbors bring your friends bring those
people who are curious about Islam bring
them during Ramadan so they can see what
goes on on a daily basis they see us in
their eating they sitting there praying
they see kids playing they see them
playing basketball football soccer and
all these different things
so now you've changed their way of
thinking now you've changed a whole
family's way of thinking just by going
and visiting experiencing and extending
that invitation to them now we know that
Islam's way of life that Jesus lived
Islam submission to the will of God
Moses Abraham the last the final message
a problem Hamid peace box and oh they
all called humanity to have a
relationship a loving relationship with
the loving God the creator of the
heavens in the earth submit to him don't
submit to the creation submit to the
crater hand and there's five pillars hmm
none is worthy of worship except the One
God paying that poor do tax praying five
times a day and you also have Hajj the
pilgrimage to the first house of worship
built by Abraham now you guys there's
some some talk that you guys are
sacrificing your your work your season
to go and make this
this drawer is hearsay no this is this
is 100% true we went and we may Oh
murder we visited mecca back in March
and when we were there we just had a
strong feeling and a strong urge to want
to come back for Hajj so there was no
way we wouldn't feel right if we signed
a contract with the team and left for
three or four weeks that wouldn't I mean
it's not Islamic you sign the contract
you honor your contract so we say you
know what we're going we're not going to
sign a contract there were a few offers
that we both had but we said we're gonna
hold off we're gonna go make Hajj and
then insha'Allah would come back we'll
try to catch on with the team after that
that's deep hum do we have a lot of
people that are reluctant they get
caught up duniya lized I call it and
they're scared of sacrifice a few weeks
they'll go make pilgrimage at the mall
every weekend or back home you know to
visit their family and friends nothing
wrong with that man when the crater has
given you the invitation to go to to his
house people are turning away but you
guys are heading out that's deep
well it truly is an invitation when like
Hussein said we weren't for home road
the lesser Hajj the lesser pilgrimage we
really felt like Allah God was welcoming
us to his house and we'd never want to
turn our back towards you know the one
who created us the one who was bestowed
all these blessings He blessed us to
plan the NFL it was nothing we did we we
were blessed to play in the NFL and
we're young we were fit where we have
the the funds to do it so why not now
definitely we're gonna get in now to the
nitty and gritty we think superstardom
we think you know the celebrity
lifestyle you get to hang around with
some of the people who are making
millions yes sir now you know temptation
yes sir it's out there you know guys
finish the game we're gonna go pop some
bottles all right we'll go to the club
come on a brother you know now how do
you you know kids at school at high
school going through this that's right
but you guys at a higher scale you are
working hard to suppress and to not get
oppressed that's right you know what I
mean by subjugating
- you know by letting your desires
override you you subjugating them
yes sir also you can be a true servant
to the one who created you live a good
moral wholesome organic life so what
advice do you have for those who are
letting their desires take charge of
their life and it's all upside down
because of them
drugs alcohol you know chasing the women
women getting you know misled by man
what advice do you have I would say when
when that starts to happen when you
start feeling like desires are just
they're just almost controlling you
start working on yourself look into the
mirror and say what can I fix about
myself how can I grow up and how can I
start making the right steps to get
married I'm 27 years old now I got
married when I was 20 I was a sophomore
in college and my freshman year in
college I got out there and I seen the
other side of college not the
educational side the other side of
comedy so I said I need to work on
myself because I don't want to fall into
these different fitness so I started to
work on myself and I took the proper
steps until I got married now we're here
something beautiful right now though the
people can hear we're hearing the call
to prayer now you guys are at work
you're throwing the ball around get
knocked down upside down right that's
somewhat intercepted like I see it right
now unis up to the ball but the call God
is greater greater than all that money
all of that wealth are you able now to
stop what you're doing and put your
forehead on the ground and prostrate to
the crater that have is an earth through
the salaat well we try our best to honor
our Salah you know we're supposed to
guide our prayers and unfortunately you
know we play at it on a Sunday afternoon
so our games are right kind of smack dab
in the middle Hussein his kick off in
Minnesota is at 12 o'clock and mine is
at 2 o'clock
al hamdulillah so Hossein usually misses
his door he has to make his up but a
humbly lot I'm able to make mine but it
really is you know when you hear the
call you know hiya little Salah you know
hasten to Salah island flat hasten to
success that's the true success so if we
can put that in front of everything else
then Allah is the most merciful he will
bless us with whatever we like that's
definitely so true we got that window of
opportunity
you know what I mean you know and and
and Allah makes it easy where you can
combine the salat on certain occasions
so you know but some people have left it
all together don't even think about it
just chasing the dollar and the money
you know that becomes something that you
know you can't take with you when you
leave this world and and I would just
say that for the brothers and the
sisters who even even if they've left it
I would just say you're a lot never
turns you down you know regardless of
what happens regardless of where you go
if you're still on this earth if you're
still breathing
then you have an opportunity to repent
to Allah spawn of Thailand and
insha'Allah Allah blesses us to continue
to hold on to that rope to hold fast to
Allah Allah Muhammad Rasulullah never
despair
Allah is the most merciful Decatur's the
most merciful so we've got so many
things to be grateful and thankful to
how without him you wouldn't be able to
run so fast you wouldn't be able to
reach your hands out to grab that ball
imagine no hands you can't even pick up
the phone you couldn't even drive the
car you just bankrupt yeah you really
bankrupt should we give things i'll
hamdulillah a lot of things yes we want
to encourage one occur to people to be
thankful and grateful and then you're
not going to be so reluctant to turn
your back I'm the creator of the heavens
and I refuse to seek His blessings
taking his bounty so you're gonna give
back themselves grateful and thankful
tell us now okay so we got the Hajj
coming up you're gonna be in
but Mecca Medina soon are you excited
I'll humbly love Mecca and Medinah were
places that you can't really describe
Medina was the most peaceful place that
I've ever been if there was ever a place
where I'd like to settle down and just
be there and just soak in the ambience
it was medina
and one thing that I really loved about
being overseas being in Mecca being
Medina was when you hear the call to
prayer everything shut down you know
there were five times a day where there
was nothing more important than
worshipping your Lord your Creator Allah
the most gracious the most merciful so
yes we're definitely excited to give
have you met we had some of the other
brothers who accepted his way of life
this beautiful way of life Islam Dave
Chappelle and he left off you know they
were talking about like a 50-50 million
15 oh yeah he went down to Mecca and he
went back to his roots I heard yourself
to Africa and he's like man you know
what the King day yes this is what I'll
leave all these big names they also when
they went back to their ruse they
figured hey it's just luck yes sir
so he went to the Hajj did you ever meet
him who else you got Omar a gun you got
Mike Tyson you know some of these big
names where actually I just got off the
phone with Omar ring and he told me to
give you his salams
and we're actually heading to Detroit to
go hang out with him right now
you get now you got to give some salams
to all the brothers down there and you
know you know the people who watch the
Deen show if they mentioned it give them
our salams when you're down to Mecca
keep us in your doing so long it's not
that special friend down there wants you
to visit actually and show law he's
watching so dr. Brown okay I'll be down
there you meet him he's a frequent
visitor here on the Deen show okay so
inshallah we're gonna take a break
and then we're going to come back with
wrapping closing comments hear from our
brothers and your brothers here on the D
so we'll be right back
a lot of you out there are in the exact
same position he said I would never give
up worshipping God is why I wouldn't
never give up spreading this message
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now just one
firefighter everything for that's what
imma jority people you talk to yeah they
know they gotta change they know they
got to do good but they don't do the
good why is this [ __ ] the ranking of the
100 most influential men in the history
of the world laziness the reality of
life usually doesn't sink in until
tragedy comes you know this is when you
find people yeah yeah okay tell me about
it yeah you get a few bad people the
media grabs ahold of that and spends it
the way they want to and in it he puts
Muhammad as number one he said no human
being had more influence one of the
amazing things about a slam that
everyone should know is that we are the
only other religion that is a tenet of
faith that you must believe in Jesus
Christ and everything that he did or you
cannot be honest if that is missing if
you say that you do not believe in Jesus
you have stepped outside of this man you
cannot be a Muslim and attended our
faith to to believe in and love Jesus
Christ
in these are not God God is the one who
created everything in his universe
that's the one I'm gonna worship and
prostrate to how can you go wrong doing
that don't believe it I'm yours out of
his long top ten reasons why Jesus
cannot be glad you did
[Music]
back here on the D show with the NFL
football players the Abdullah brothers
catching the ball thought you did you
did you ever want to be Porter back
everybody wants to be the quarterback
cuz he he gets the ball you touch the
ball every single play it's about
touching it really is about the football
is so simple all football is is you stop
the guy or if you have the ball you try
and cross the line and if you don't have
the ball you try to stop the guy from
crossing the line I always wanted to be
a running back very Sanders with my
favorite player growing up and not
that's kind of who I really like no one
to be a running back and then I realize
hitting people with fun science became a
safety I'm sorry I get to talk a little
bit about football with you brothers I
don't know much about football I'm more
into the martial arts al hamdulillah
shaolong I heard you guys maybe want to
start training Brazilian jiu-jitsu that
will be nice and short long you can be
our instructor here in Chicago but maybe
we'll hook you up with some some people
our organization has branches all over
the globe so we can hook you up with the
Gracie Baja team somewhere in your
locality and she'll tell us now again
going back to this serious matter you
know purpose of life why we've been
created is just to have fun party and
then die that's not what it's about you
guys realize that right yes and you you
started to live this way of life that's
about bringing peace into your life
purpose when you have purposed and you
know you peace comes so now you are
worshipping none but the one who created
you that's Islam submission to only the
crater establishing the salaat we talked
about Hajj okay you guys are doing the
Hajj the five pillars and we don't
really want to get you know are not yet
Muslims out there motivated to think
what the purpose of life is why I'm here
you know what I mean that's why we share
because we care that's right right so
now fasting also Jesus fasted Moses
faster they only worship the Creator
they also gave in charity and this is
the five pillars of Islam nothing
different nothing unique we're not from
outer space now so now the fasting comes
into plate and people get excited
they're like how did these guys do it
you're fast
and your plane how does that work
fastening and playing football we
started doing it at a young age and our
mother once again she pointed to Hakeem
Olajuwon she said he's fasting he's
playing basketball and he's dominating
his sport so from there as competitive
as we are we say you know it if he can
do it in Shiloh we can do it and we
started working that in and and in that
fastening is a part of our religion
football is not so fasting comes before
football so if there was ever a fasting
or football of course we're going to
choose fasting and I would just just add
on to that is you know the first thing
we have to do regardless of what we're
doing especially while we're fasting is
we ask Allah to make it easy for us so
we do that first thing is to ask a lot
you know o Allah please make it easy for
us the second thing is we have to do our
part you're fasting it's hot you're
doing extracurricular activities you
have to hydrate yourself you have to eat
properly you have to have a nutrition
plan you have to educate the people
around you to let them know that you're
fasting and what you're doing because
we're not belligerent Allah doesn't
place on this burden greater than we can
bear and we have to remember that okay
let's go into this now you know many of
the youth even adults they look up to
you guys you know NFL that's a multi
what billion billion dollar industry
right so okay a lot of people listen to
you before they listen to you know some
of the laymen and they look at you and
they maybe look at their parents say you
guys don't understand you know what I
mean
so now they're let's say slacking in
school or some are getting a good grades
but now their priorities are mixed up
they're thinking I'm gonna get the good
grades get the good title get the nice
car get the nice woman the guys thinking
okay I'm gonna work hard and party hard
right so I mean is that the right
direction to go in life and how could we
persuade people to to be more into the
Dean
instead of being more into you know the
dunya and the nightclubs and all the
other things I just you know don't don't
bring peace and happiness drugs alcohol
gambling all these things that just
destroy a person will destroy once I was
I would say there's a reason why your
parents were placed in your household we
didn't choose our parents a lot chose
our parents for us and those are the
best role models to look at your father
and see how he carries himself you
mother how she carries herself and
everybody they looks they look at us
because we were a jersey and we have the
NFL logo on it but I mean I hummed a lot
but you can look and you can look at
your parents as a role model you can
look at your older brothers or sisters
look within your community and see the
examples that are put right in front of
your face we don't always have to look
to a to a certain person on YouTube or
to an athlete or to a somebody of
so-called status you can look right
inside your home and you can find some
of the best role models ever and then
just to add to that I would just say you
know guard your prayer when you guard
your prayers when you when you're
constantly thinking about Allah that
takes you away from a lot of the
distractions so inshallah you know I'm
when we speak we speak for ourselves you
know because we're trying to get better
every single day
so inshallah that's one thing that I
noticed that more the more I frequent
the Masjid the more I interact with
those brothers and sisters who are there
constantly the more I want to attach
myself to the mantra the more I wanted
to be like those brothers and sisters or
be like my father who can't stay away
from the Mazdas longer than a few hours
so those are the role models those are
the ones that we look to and we do
understand that we're on the platform
and with that you know inshallah just
please make it we ask Allah to make it
easy for us and bless us to be good
examples but know that we're human being
and we're working on ourselves just as
they can work on themselves now if
you're trying to be righteous you're
trying to give up the alcohol you know
the six-packs you can whatever you're
drinking you're trying to give up you
know smoking we all right that's like a
big thing you know the bad stuff is just
bad you know lying deceiving but now
you've realized that you realize that I
am created for a purpose it's more noble
err than this but now you're trying to
do good but you got you know your
friends they calling you on the weekend
thank you I gotta go I'll lend you some
I'm sorry somewhat I'm sorry it seems
like I'm getting sucked at get back in
how important is a good company it's
it's very important and it's very
important to guard your inner circle
back when I was in high school I had
some people that was not so good in my
inner sir
and my father was like no no no and I
and at the time I didn't understand but
later on in life I seen the direction
they chosen life in the direction I was
head in life and I was like you know
what he was right because whoever's in
your inner circle will rub off on you
and they will say oh we're just gonna go
hang out real quick you don't need any
money I got the gas I got your movie
ticket I got whatever just come hang out
with us now you're in a situation that
you don't want to be in so you have to
keep good company you have to protect
and guard your inner circle and what we
always say is what our mom taught us
when we were younger one for your
brother what you want for yourself so if
you're around people who don't want for
you what they want for themselves if
they won't they won't you know they
won't labor and they'll throw you in
somewhere you know maybe you guys are in
trouble or he's in trouble so he throws
your name in there that's not wanting
for your brother what you want for
yourself so you want to align yourselves
with like-minded people people have the
same more of the same bodies even if
they're not Muslim there's some other
people out there who are morally
conscious and who are going to do the
right thing so inshallah what we like to
do God willing it's align ourselves with
people that are close and close and
character to us it's really important
really important that's right that's
right
that is true statement so you know you
want to become righteous you want to
please your Creator before you meet your
Creator you want to be doing good should
be around people are doing good you got
a person that's disrespecting his
parents or her parents and using foul
language you know of course you want
advise him to good but then you're
hanging around with somebody who's
constantly doing that they're gonna be
bringing you down that's right and you
don't want you won't you don't ever want
to go down you always want to go up
there's a few sayings in football you're
even getting right or you're getting
left so in other words you need to get
going and you never stay the same you're
either getting better or you're getting
worse so we won't always be getting
better always being the worship of Allah
even if you're not Muslim you always
want to give thanks to the Creator the
person who created you because it was
like that BAM being you were so we
always want to remember that and give
thanks to the Most High
we can't ever this is advice to our
brothers and sisters but man we can
never leave our sisters out we love them
months and you know we're talking about
real issues here on the Dean show so you
know you got the sisters who are so
precious they're more pressure than the
love to us than diamonds and pearls you
know Islam elevates the woman in does it
subjugate the woman are pressed the
woman and we cover so many episodes
giving the evidence is improve so what
advice for our sisters some of them they
getting you know led astray by a lot of
the brothers out there who are you know
man that's right now you see it at a
higher level you know use less in women
so advice we give for our sisters out
there so that will get used and abused I
would say again it starts in the
household listen to your father listen
to your older brother there your there
your protectors don't don't go against
the grain and you know you meet a guy or
whatever the case may be make sure
everything checks out
because when you turn your back on your
family it's hard to cross that line
again so I would say start with their
protectors in your house and and ask
them because they've had examples with
with women and they know different
things so those are examples that they
can talk about and they can learn from
before they experience it themselves and
I would just add that you know as for
men and for women is to educate
ourselves you know do not let CNN or Fox
News tell us what Islam is about read
the Koran read the hadith read the
different books that are out there about
the four most beautiful women on the
history of the planet read about Miriam
and sort of Miriam Illes Salaam in the
Koran and see if she's oppressed see how
she was veiled and those different
things that can teach us about our
religion and for our sisters that we
have a stronger going what what what
they have on the west and in America and
what they feel is a beautiful woman is
not so what's a beautiful woman is a
woman of strong character who can take
care of her children take care of her
husband and still go to bed she can be a
businesswoman she can be all those
things but the four greatest woman in
Islam were people who are near and dear
to prophets peace be upon them we're
almost out of time I just thought I'm
gonna ask you a couple more questions
you know this is something that
sometimes it's just laughable some of
the misconceptions the false fallacies
that are out there about Islam and I'm
throwing out some charts right here to
show that it's at the lowest of totem
pole when the FBI statistics and they
show that
Lahm has you know the least amount of
terror acts and people like try to flip
it and make it seem like it's lot
Muslims are out there just causing havoc
on earth even though we're all about
peace and trying to make peace and live
according to the way of life of peace so
when you guys hear Islam being maligned
out there that sight in your heart it
really does and it's unfortunate that
they do that but I would say don't
listen to the media go and do it
yourself we're we're doing it we're
driving around going to the different
match and sometimes we should show up
unannounced just to see the kind of
reception that we get because we're
African Americans a lot of people think
oh you have to be a foreigner to be a
Muslim no you just go in and ever say
Salam alaikum everybody greets you the
same so for all the non-muslims out
there I would say if you really want to
know about Islam just walk into the
master and it is a beautiful scene and
that's why I love America because
America was founded on immigrants you
know there's no one who said oh I've
been here my family's been here since
the 600 BC no everyone came from
somewhere else and you look in the
different massages and the different
mosques that we've been to around the
country and there's someone of every
ethnicity right there standing
toe-to-toe and praising the one and only
allah subhanaw taala and it's such a
beautiful sight that I recommend that
Muslims and non-muslims go out of your
comfort zone if this is your area this
is your bubble step out of there go to a
mosque out of your area and go see how
they interact with you I'm dying to ask
you this before we leave like when
you're on the football field and now you
know the opposite team today do they say
things and try to you know provoke you
and try to throw you off your game like
they'll be sometimes it gets where it's
not personal obviously or maybe it might
get personal do you have other remarks
coming from other players when you're
out there and getting ready to before it
goes like Snap balls for the ball is now
but in the inner field not necessarily I
will say back in high school you may get
a pork joke here there but that's what I
mean like now that you're on the under
line and the guys are like we're gonna
get you
[Laughter]
I haven't heard anything like that just
I would just say the regular smack talk
we're not necessarily making a farm to
write tour in India okay
man this is beautiful thank you guys for
home loss how could people now look you
up up again to know where you guys are
gonna be this the most of the cities
that you're gonna be in they can hit us
up go to our website Abdullah Bros
dot-com they can also go to our Facebook
page facebook.com slash Abdullah
brothers they can follow us on twitter
at Abdullah Bros thank you guys thank
you so much me the creditor hammers ours
rewards you for you know you what you
guys are doing is wonderful project and
shall law we can beat about it back
together again sometime and there you
having some great advice from the NFL
players the Abdullah brothers you can
see while many people are having a hard
time because of the dollar because of
the fame they're forgetting about their
purpose in life why they've been created
why they're here the brothers haven't
forgotten so they're giving back and
it's time for HUDs they're answering the
call it's time for prayer that stopping
to pray it's time to fast they're
fasting and that's what Islam is about
the same way of life that Abraham Moses
Noah and all the other messages that God
Almighty has sent to mankind because he
loves mankind he wants to guide mankind
don't turn away from the guidance in the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
they all were brothers of one another
and they came with the same one message
only worship the one who created
creation the one create tour and Arabic
we say Allah and Aramaic jesus said
Allah ha that's the one God and work to
develop yourself to be the best that you
can be being in a constant state of
self-development you can't do it on your
own whims and desires that's why God
Almighty revealed the five pillars
praying fasting giving in charity doing
the Hajj not because he needs it because
this is if you want to get big you hit
the bench press you want to get some
good conditioning you're on you want to
develop God consciousness you go ahead
and you obey God and you become more
cognizant of your purpose in life you
reflect more you ponder more not about
the money in the big house and the cars
in the bling-bling but you ponder about
the day of judgment that you're going to
be accountable when you die for all the
things you've done in this life there's
a Hellfire there's a paradise and I want
to be those who enter the paradise and
the only way you can do it is by
submitting to the will of God and doing
good and being good and living your
purpose in life living your purpose in
life so do it right now ask if you
haven't do it right now ask within
yourself God Almighty guide me guide me
guide me to that which is pleasing to
you give us a call 1 800 662 help some
misconceptions that you like for us to
answer call us visit the mocha moistures
in your area visit the Abdullah brothers
and talk to them talk to them and you
can see that Muslims are those who want
to acquire peace we want peace but we're
seeking it from the owner peace the one
who created this whole universe and
everything in it so alhamdulillah we got
some great advice from these brothers
here today if you're young out there and
you're striving to go ahead and finish
college and finish school go ahead and
be the best doctor engineer mechanic
whatever it is but don't forget your
purpose in life don't forget why Allah
the creator created you and lived that
purpose and visit us here every week on
the deen show for you can visit us also
at the Deen show com
don't forget to pick up the new dunya to
dien also and we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be with you
[Music]